here are the nominees for achievement
and sound mixing black panther Steve Bo
Decker
Brandon Proctor and Peter devil will him
Ian Rhapsody Paul Massey timki vegan and
John Cazale first man John Taylor
Frankie Montano Eiling Lee and Mary age
Ellis
Roma skip web see Drake Hannigan
and Jose Antonio Garcia the star is born
tom was a niche demon Japan's ik Jason
Ritter and Steve Moore
and the Oscar goes to Bohemian Rhapsody
this is the first Oscar game for this
sound mixing
Paul Massey has eight previous
nominations receiving this first but
it's work on legends of the ball Tim
Kabat game was previously nominated in
this category for baby driver and this
is the first job
the John Cazale
[Music]
Thank You Academy huge honor like to
think our producers Graham King Dennis
O'Sullivan Ted Galliano from Fox and our
whole sound crew thank you
a massive shout out to Brian May and
Roger Taylor thank you so much for your
music and for your collaboration and
your support and I would like to
dedicate this to my kids Sean Andrew
Sophie Taylor I love you all thank you I
want to thank my wife my kids
Olivia Joe Steven and Gemma honored my
team amber this is really for Chris
Murphy my boom operator that's probably
for 14 years
thanks mate thank you I'd like to thank
team Twickenham our circuit everyone
else who worked on the sound in this
incredible movie - my mom and dad my
amazing brothers and - my friends back
in odium watching tonight thank you